irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
au pays hôte et les gens aux visages
brûlés autrement dit en ethiopie pendant
trois mois les nuages s'amoncellent
obstinément et soudain cref c'est
s'abattre en trombe sur les hauts
plateaux
le 26 septembre de chaque année marque
la fin de la saison des pluies de début
de la nouvelle année la fête de l'ama
squale annonce des choses heureuses h
messe est par exemple guy franchissable
autrement dit la reprise des voyages et
celle de la vie normale interrompue
pendant trois mois
la nature fait bien les choses seuls les
sages sable comprendre et avoir la
patience de l'entente en vraiment les
informent au comme de véritables petits
arbres sont gorgés d'eau ce qui leur
permet de résister au mois de sécheresse
à demi mot la nature devient un
véritable jardin c'est la récompense
pour l'oeil des trois mois l'aise et
pénible l'aloès lui-même cesse de bouder
et et refleurit tout est flou c'est
alors qu'addis abeba prend toute sa
signification puisque elle veut dire la
nouvelle fleur mais pour l'instant nous
sommes encore dans la campagne et le
plateau eux ne sont que marguerite jaune
on les appelle fleurs de l'ama squale en
a marre août
cela signifie ouah
mais un jour de la fête arrive et
puisque l'on va être heureux il faut le
crier aux quatre coins du pays
les hommes vont être heureux alors
l'avant garde les enfants eux le sont
déjà
ils se ruent dans les prairies pour
reconnaître la douceur de l'herbe que
foule leurs pieds et le jaune de la
marguerite qui ne vont cueillir canton
sam elle fidèles à leur tradition elles
prépareront le festin du soir autre
tradition amusante l'aînée des petites
filles portent autour de son cou le
corps d'un de cure gens auxquels est
suspendu un bibelot d'argent
les animaux sont soignés et heureux de
trouver tant d'eau
les enfants se réjouissent aussi et
après le départ des vaches des chevaux
les hommes arrivent en cours en groupe
et par ménage pendant qu ils resteront
ainsi réuni contrôle du même village à
danser certains viennent avec leurs murs
richement tarn à chaud car là-bas la
mule demeure flou dans la nuit un
personnage assez pénible relief
accidenté
il est très hasardeux de donner des
chiffres là même le recensement des
hommes n'est qu'apparent ces natifs
maison peu évaluée à environ un million
le nombre de murs et les courants de
faire des voyages de 6 à 8 jours à dos
de mule une âme bien plus parce qu'il va
être un peu fatigante au bord du lac la
foule devient de plus en plus grande de
plus en plus dense et les jeux le
divertissement les danses commence ce
sont d'abord des groupes d'hommes qui
armés de bâtons mime d'imaginaire combat
en chantant leurs chants régionaux au
profit des pentes accidenté pour voir le
spectacle les spectateurs sont nombreux
et stoïque
karine assiste debout assez dense qui
commence le matin c'était un enfant
avant dans la nuit parmi les danseurs
vous allez leur marque et ses portes de
cours de violon sur la tête c'est parce
qu'ils ont pu et et un lien
cela vous donne là bas un prestige
énorme la fête chrétienne de la masse
coin représentant à la fois l'invention
de la croix l'exaltation dans quoi a été
adopté par les gallas les païens eux
mêmes on célèbre le culte sans en
comprendre la signification cette fête
certainement bien antérieure à la
christianisation c'est la salle du
renouveau la nature
en tout cas c'est une bonne occasion
conserver le pied si on en croit ses
charmantes créatures les femmes la fesci
vont retourner à la fête où elles
passeront la fin de la soirée à
s'inviter en cadence
addis abeba place saint-georges plein
centre de la foule est dense et chacun
porte ses bouquets au bout de longues
perches
on attendait quelqu'un le voici c'est
l'empereur sa majesté haïlé sélassié il
va être reçue par la bouna chef suprême
de l'église
les dignitaires
et au centre de la place se dresse ceci
pyramide fait de troncs d'eucalyptus
garni de bouquets et de croire
car la masse qualcomm est mort aussi la
découverte de la vraie croix par sainte
hélène souvenez vous la belle actrice
ellen avait demandé aux vieillards de
jérusalem de lui indiquer l'emplacement
de la vraie croix ils ne purent l'avancé
nié alors refi d'édifier un bûcher et
supplier adieu d'en diriger la fumée
vers l'endroit où se trouvait la sainte
croix
elle fut exaucé et trois jours de
fouilles à l'endroit désigné tenir à
jour trois croix de bois qui furent
considérés comme celle de jésus et des
deux larrons
souvenez-vous du miracle il y en avait
trois une seule ne pouvait être que
celle du triste un cadavre fut allongé
successivement sur les 3,3 et l'une
virant dynavie la reine ordonna de
dresser un grand mât et d'y mettre le
feu à cinq nuls chrétiens de
constantinople new yor la bonne nouvelle
voilà tout symbole de la masse quoi
en principe ne plus s'arrêter net la
veille de la fête
mais pour le carde la nature ferait une
erreur deux jours et où ils tomberaient
de trombes d'eau une tente est toujours
dressés pour recevoir un trône de
l'empereur
m
dans toutes les villes et tous les
villages ses revenus d'antiques
hamon
antoinat
la boon a béni la foule et le mas de la
main ce coin puis le prg au grand
complet évêques prêtres bien pour ça
triste 1 l'étude l'europe de brocart
richement sur brodeur chemine trois fois
autour de la pyramide en sens inverse
des aiguilles d'une montre
le chiffre trois est choisi à kaunas en
clinique
une opr s'avance lentement avec à ses
côtés la masse casse à son cousin
il est suivi du prince héritier et du
but de hammam son seul office dernière
et le corps diplomatique
trois fois au sou lentement il fait le
tour des mains avant de regagner son
trou les hommes défilent en rangs serrés
ils portent leur bouquet de masques wall
au bout de leurs perches
ils ont tous grimpé dans leur chama
nationale
le feu va être mis aux pyramides et
toute la nuit se passe dans les champs
les faits dans toutes les provinces de
l'empiré au lieu des danses des
réjouissances il a plu en a cessé de
tomber
ce concours
yoann chagnaud vous a présenté voyage
son passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de maxime
plairait de solange péters montage
michel la touffe script lui cette
embellie prise de son jean-paul tic
emploi illustration sonore bernard andré
réty